il y a une énorme attente du débat qui
va commencer ici demain et ce d'autant
plus que celui à l'Assemblée nationale
qui n'a même pas été jusqu'au principal
article a offert un spectacle parfois
désolé
pourtant quand il a eu lieu il a été
éclairant sur les femmes qui
contrairement à vos affirmations sont
les principales victimes de votre texte
mais aussi quand vous nous parliez des
prétendus 1,8 millions de concernés par
une retraite minimum à 1200 euros devenu
40000 et finalement de 10 à 20 000 au
Sénat nous la gauche nous allons
poursuivre ce travail de vérité nous
serons en écho avec une très grande
majorité de nos concitoyens et avec des
syndicats Unis qui appellent à ce que
notre pays s'arrête le 7 mars pour dire
non à cette régression sociale nous
débattrons cet article 7 qui est un
impôt sur la vie des plus modestes et
chacun ici devra prendre ses
responsabilités par son vote pour ou
contre deux ans de plus pour celles et
ceux qui ont déjà travaillé dur toute
leur vie mais nous sommes ici attachés
au débat de fond et le fond comme la
démocratie demande du temps celui de
l'argumentation et de l'écoute celui de
l'amendement et de l'explication de
votre libre pour chacun qui sont des
droits sacrés des parlementaires alors
je vous le demande allez-vous encore
empêcher ce débat en le brutalisant en
le menaçant d'interruption alors qu'il
s'agit d'une loi qui touche à la vie de
millions de nos concitoyens faute
d'avoir recherché un accord acceptable
avec les syndicats est-ce que cette
limitation fait partie de l'accord des
droites que vous auquel vous avez
consacré tant d'énergie que vous avez
négocié avec LR au Sénat pour faire
passer cette réforme injuste et inutile